good
[Music]
hello how are you and I greet you in 3 gonzález with
the most outstanding news of the day
nevadas is among the seven states of the
country that will have primary elections
today these elections are
different since the voting was
done by mail due to the  pandemic
and as a precautionary measure some of
the most anticipated races include
the two us congressional seats
from nevada's 3rd and 4th districts
currently democrats subtle
and stephen horford hold those
positions for his part he is useful and fighting
to keep his seat  before two
democrats and six republicans who
seek to take their place while
horford has five
democrat opponents and eight republicans who
compete against the congressman
there is also a lot of expectation of who will take
the 6 positions currently on the
clark county board of commissioners
there are also two seats  of the
supreme court that are part of these
primary elections l  he
general and presidential elections are set to take place
next november
in other news
bail has been set for three men
who are accused of organizing an attack
on blacklight smer protests steven has been baild
for salt
and roll in an william blum  it's
altogether a million dollars the
officers have mentioned that these
people are members of the
boogaloo movement a group based on
white supremacy and
anti-government beliefs this morning they were still
in state custody
the department of motor vehicles
better known as  shipping will begin
a phased reopening starting
next Monday, June 15 for the
first 30 days the djembe will only
serve users with immediate needs
including car sales to
individuals suspended driver's license
without a valid Haitian form or
newly purchased vehicle  no badges
only users and attendees
need  services such as
language interpreters will be allowed inside the
building the city of las vegas' has
teamed up with the health district and the
station casinos hotel group to
provide
coi 19 testing to the public testing will be
administered today tomorrow  from eight in the
morning to two in the afternoon at the texas
station you do not need to make an appointment
and now we move on to the temperatures
less wind is expected today with a maximum
of 88 degrees and a minimum of 60
for tomorrow it will be hotter
I am andrés  gonzález and this was in
disney in spanish
[Music]